la pandemia hundió la economía de
bolivia que vive su peor año en casi
siete décadas en vísperas de navidad la
crisis se ve en las calles con niños y
adultos tratando de ganar monedas dos de
estos menores son hijos de adela huánuco
que vende gelatinas cata hijos tengo el
pre vendían gelatina aquí me vengo a
vender cada día
de todo mingo nomás no salgo
en la casa de tienda también
las cosas gargantas rápidamente
cerca de la paz viven adela de 35 años y
su esposo rolando flores de 46 antes de
la pandemia ella lavaba ropa a mano para
terceros y él era taxista y tenía
eventuales trabajos en la construcción
rolando perdió ambos empleos y es muy
pesimista acerca de su futuro si
realmente estamos todos muy desanimados
como quien dice de vivir la vida porque
ya todo es que se ha dado totalmente
llano de platita ya no es trabajo ya no
hay nada como miles de bolivianos
adela y su familia no tiene previsto
hacer nada para navidad así nomás lo
vamos a pasar hasta que se normalice
está de resultados pero que dos años un
año habrá alguien para la vida
adela y rolando quieren el nuevo bono
contra el hambre de 143 dólares pero
quizá no sean beneficiados porque han
cobrado otras ayudas sin embargo el
presidente luis arse ha prometido que
llegará al mayor número de personas
los esfuerzos necesarios para que esa
gente esos bolivianos y bolivianas
también pues reciban del estado lo que
se merecen para poder de alguna manera
palear todo el sufrimiento todo el
hambre que se ha vivido y es que esta
será una navidad sin brillo tras un año
para el olvido